i
just want to shout y'all out man because
i feel like um i was just telling you
before the interview started like this
record with wale i feel like is
you know you guys have put out amazing
records before i'm a real fan of what
y'all do
but like when i heard this song i was
like interscope got a real like
radio record to work like this could be
like a real hit record for y'all
appreciate that man yeah man
you know it's just it's just one of
those records where we like to always
give the people something that they can
you know i'm saying live with you know
saying like outside the homes outside
the headphones you know what i'm saying
like
this we'll just create music where
people could like move around and do
life too you know
yeah even in the pandemic when everybody
inside and stuff but it's like
you know we need that energy to you know
everybody don't need to be sitting down
the whole time and [ __ ]
no for sure i think like also you guys
you
you know you mentioned the pandemic like
thank you for for you know your the
contributions to the spillage village
album because
uh yeah thank you bro yeah that was uh
much needed last year
yeah yeah yeah yeah it was a good vibe
man it's a good good time to make it to
the
time yeah you know for people who don't
uh kind of know i i kind of look at you
guys as like um
it's like kind of like the closest thing
to what we have to dungeon family in
2020 2021 you know yeah and i know you
guys have been rocking for a long time
a lot of people think that that's like
the first project but you guys have
other projects
yeah yeah yeah yeah like marie was fire
um obviously you know jid black
kind of co you know i spoke with j.i.d a
bit about
um kind of his roots with spillage
village and like
his early roots with mariba and um and
black um but how did you guys all
form the collective like like initially
because like i said it's
got an energy that is very reminiscent
of
you know some of the 90s hip-hop
collectives you know like some native
tongue [ __ ] you know what i mean
initially it was just us jit and uh and
well and this was just us jit and and
hollywood jb
like initially because we all went to
school together and then uh
once we all got out of school came back
to atlanta we didn't really know what to
do with ourselves much other than keep
hanging out you know what i'm saying
keep hanging out making music so
then we we laid down with marieba who we
met while we was in school and she was
still living here
she started coming over more naturally
it's like black
you know i'm saying hollywood jb brought
his brother jordan
and and then christo who is jizz
producer and dj bro his brother benji
was all just like we're actually just
hanging out together all the time anyway
just making music all the time anyway
and then it was like where we going
what do we call this it's like a village
bros and we keep culture the spillage
village because
the ideas just kept coming out that's
all we ever did we got together
yeah it's crazy too because i don't
think like people really you know
black kind of had a meteoric rise
in the last three or four years you know
and i don't think people really kind of
um
understand like his roots uh in in this
[ __ ]
you know what i'm saying right and even
just like his talent is like an emcee
you know what i mean like he could wrap
his [ __ ] ass up
yeah like was that something like
because i i remember when his [ __ ]
started to kind of initially take off on
soundcloud
um and there was like a lot of mystery
behind it but you guys being around him
early on did you guys kind of always
feel like
like he was a star it was just a matter
of time yeah he was just super focused
you know what i'm saying when i first we
first met black i remember him talking
about
like deals he got in and out of in high
school bro in high school he definitely
wasn't talking about no deals
wow you know like i mean you know he
just had
he had a a a different exposure to the
game that
we could that we all learn from you know
i think part of what has made spielberg
so great was along this time
we all have learned stuff from each
other you know i'm saying we've all like
taken a little like humorous stuff from
jed or like you know saying
something like vocal
[Music]
um black used to when he first would do
his melodies
he would have the mic super turned up
super high and be saying them very
softly so he would be sleeping in the
living room
and wake up in the middle of the night
or make them in the middle of the day
and just be recording and i'm like what
are you doing over there i didn't know
he was actually making stuff
and then he'll play it and be like okay
wow that's a cool technique so he was
always like picking up on each other
techniques like
the whole time he's like all living in
the same house that's an interesting
recording technique
it's almost like you could kind of be
like off off in the corner locally
that's what he's just turning up your
levels like crazy
he would have everything turned up on
his end and he would just be in there
wow and then by the time he would play
it for us like like yo you just did that
like when while he's over here
like you guys are playing too okay yeah
man whatever we didn't even hear him
doing that we look back that's fine